down here
we have um the furniture
that she had in her growing up room
they're very proud of britney spears in
her hometown of kentwood in louisiana
her life of course has been quite a
journey from here
and who controls that life now is the
subject of intense speculation
out of all the fame and adulation her
stories become a cautionary tale for
young celebrities
this is free 102. while this documentary
raised questions about the 13 years
she's spent subject
to illegal conservatorship she's been
largely silent
for the podcasters who probe the dark
side of her story
hearing her in court is a big moment my
immediate hope for her is that she gets
to say
what she wants to say and that she's
listened to ultimately i do hope that
she's able to be autonomous
the terms for a conservatorship is that
someone's unable to clothe feed or
shelter themselves
and britney spears can you know do all
of those things so
it's just an extremely upsetting
situation she's in and i think that
that's why so many people are interested
in it
lawyers say she does have some control
she had the opportunity to request a
termination
of the conservatorship and so far we
have not seen her ask for that we know
that she's unhappy with her dad
being in the role of conservator and she
wants that person removed out
i think she should have what she wants
[Music]
a whole movement's been born out of
britney's legal affairs
and they say it now goes way beyond her
our first and main focus is to get
brittany free from these restraints but
also
to raise awareness about this this
threat that's
out there as far as probate
conservatorships that come in and
take over a person's life and and their
money it could happen to any of us
we've been told as fans it's none of our
business to stay out of it
and that's why it's continued for so
long i think brittany means a lot to a
lot of people um
that's certainly true for myself i think
that
just she has been judged so harshly
by society i believe that britney will
be free
one day one way or another the fans look
to her social media posts for clues as
to what she really
thinks her father says the
conservatorship
protects her she herself has requested
this court hearing
in her own words she will at last tell
her side of this story
greg milam sky news los angeles